[Music]
we live in a world that is increasingly
polarized left and right north and south
red and blue black and white if I'm
right you must be wrong but the reality
is we live in shades of grey many many
shades of uncomfortable gray and we have
a responsibility to manage that grey
that's why I wanted to talk to Jenna
Arnold the author of raising our hands
she's a pot stirrer and has big opinions
about our individual responsibility to
contribute to the collective good this
is a bit of optimism what I wanted to
talk to you about was affective
disruption I think it's a misunderstood
concept what it takes to affect change
and you more than a lot of people know
what it takes to affect change what
bothers me so much about this term
disruption is it feels like it's a
jostling of peace and there's both
negative peace and positive peace and
peace in some people's interpretation is
status quo in other people's it's
complacency and apathy and those kinds
of things need to get jostled and they
need to get disrupted but the term
disruption has always bothered me I like
to think of myself more as a pot stirrer
this is what you're so good at it's the
thing that I'm of all the things that
I'm a fan of about you my favorite thing
is your ability to hold a mirror up I
guess as you call it stir the pot and so
with that mirror held up and that's
what's happening to us now which is
we're all looking in this mirror some
willingly simba grudgingly and we're
seeing things that are making us
uncomfortable about ourselves
realizations and what are we supposed to
do it's not enough to simply say fix it
you know because this is human-being
stuff sometimes we may not know how to
fix it how do I remove a bias that I
didn't even know I had I call it the
grace of the gray it's this concept of
the grace of the gray that we are right
now sitting in a lot of grayness because
we're not actually sure what the next
right step is and so it's this idea of
there's going to be 10,000 baby steps
between here and wherever it is that we
collectively want to go and so one of
the things that I invite us all to do is
instead of trying to figure out the book
the podcast the webinar the zoom yes to
all of those things is to recognize that
one we all particularly the privileged
class have it's not 400 years people
keep saying 400 years
it's like thousands of years of
assumptions that are baked into our DNA
that we have to unpack we are all here
in a time that is extraordinarily
complex there will be departments built
around this moment at major universities
and we'll be studying it well beyond our
lives and so what I invite people to do
is instead of saying like I don't want
to do the bad thing I don't want to do
the good thing is like again remove the
binary write the binary is how this
country has been set up your other good
bad your Republican Democrat you're on
the winning team you're on the losing
team we can't live in that yes or no
space anymore we have to live in the
middle which means that instead of
searching for answers we have to search
for questions so the next best thing for
us constantly is what do I need to do
now maybe it is a book maybe it is
looking at our employee handbooks in our
companies maybe it is looking at our
boardrooms are they primarily white are
they primarily male maybe it is looking
at our rolodex and being like wow I got
a lot of white people in here maybe it
is the next time you're driving behind a
slow driver and you're like ah it's
probably one of those awful explicit
stereotypes you catch yourself doing
that one of the listening circle
participants and these are the steps
that are part of the process we had had
a conversation about racial biases and
she emailed me a week or two after the
conversation that we had and she said
okay Jenna I was in the checkout line in
a grocery store and I was standing
behind a black man who was in a
beautiful cashmere sweater and we were
chit-chatting and while we were in
conversation I thought to myself if he
weren't in a beautiful cashmere zip-up
sweater I would not be chit-chatting
with him and that's the work being
honest with yourself about those ugly
truth
so it's being really honest with
ourselves about our biases which are
going to take a lifetime and I always
say this I'm in first grade on this
stuff and I might graduate to second at
some point in my life there's some
language that we can put in place that's
gonna raise the bar for us but on a
personal level it's asking her questions
this idea of the race of gray is is a
bigger idea than I think people realize
and I mean look it's it's a human thing
but for at least the last 30 or 40 years
there's been a steady drumbeat in the
United States to move away from gray and
move towards black and white we've
become more binary in how we view the
world we've become more separated you
know the idea of cooperation and you
know this from your own career it used
to be in politics that 80% of the
negotiating was done behind closed doors
the last 20% was for the cameras and the
goal was that both parties could go back
to the constituents and said we got what
we want in other words both could claim
a win now a hundred percent it's done in
front of the cameras and it's not enough
for us to go back to our constituents
and say we got what we want we also have
to say and they didn't we have to win
and they have to lose which in a game
that has no finish line is a
preposterous idea there is such thing as
two winners like in business more than
one company can make money and be
successful selling the same product
there is enough there's enough success
to go around and so I think there's so
many things that are happening in this
moment in politics in business in social
movement that is the result of an
extreme amount of pressure and tension
of a human animal that by its very
nature lives in gray all relationships
are gray all interactions amongst humans
are shades of grey and we now in this
modern day both good and bad to be
binary about it want to put everything
in a bucket that's right wrong good bad
yes no winning winning winning losing
and if I'm right then you have to be
wrong and this idea of gray and I'd love
this this idea of gray requires asking
questions as opposed to having answers
this idea of gray has to involve
listening
unless talking has to have empathy over
judgment for ourselves to all around all
around and this idea of gray is for all
parties this is for police and the
community there's a lot of gray in all
of these it's for black and brown and
white there's a lot of gray in all of
this color and the binary flare-ups if
we want to call it that is very
important to get the mirror up to stir
the pot to start the conversations but
then the gray must must be allowed to
exist in perpetuity in perpetuity into
your point at best we're in first grade
most of us are still playing with blocks
and we will spend our lifetime with good
intentions working on this and if we're
really lucky to your point by the end of
our lives we might as a nation and as
individuals get to second grade and the
point is is this is not a race to be won
this is a movement or a cause to be
advanced we are moving ever and ever
closer to an ideal that we imagine
knowing full well we'll never get there
Martin Luther King's dream will never be
realized but we will die trying to get
there that is the point the point is
that we can look backwards and say we
have moved we have made progress and
there is still work to be done you know
this in marriage marriage has gray and
is never perfect but it is it is a
striving and that's what grey is
striving that's right one of the things
that binary has come out of and I want
to make sure that this isn't a
permission slip I'm not pardoning us and
our behavior and our ignorance --is
which people have been asking for
centuries for us to pay attention to but
one of the causes of them are our
textbooks and the narrative or about our
country we've been told for centuries
that the people who found in our country
we're seven foot tall white men who
always knew what to do they always made
the good decisions and so far for the
most part we've been victorious enough
that the victors got to tell their
stories and so if you look in our
textbooks the victorious have told their
stories
ways that make they're very difficult
decision-making right all the time and
so when we're suddenly in a place of
insecurity and I don't know Ness when
we're suddenly being pushed back into a
grey there's this belief in this
narrative that we've been told that
you're supposed to know the answer to
this and if you don't find the person
who does and a little bit follow them
blindly this is very interesting to me
this binary nasai in leadership in terms
of pretending that you know all the
answers even when you don't cuz if I
don't know the answers then I must not
be a leader right and or someone's gonna
figure me out or that someone's gonna
figure me yet and there's great irony in
this because the best leaders are the
ones that are extremely comfortable in
the grey the best leaders the ones who
are able to say I don't know trying to
figure it out here's what I think here's
what I hope but I don't know and one of
the things I learned from dr. James Kars
who wrote finite and infinite games is
that a finite mindset when you see the
world in black and white right and wrong
win and lose the finite mindset hates
surprises
uncertainty scares them completely which
is why they try to exert control and
which is why time frames become very
short because we can exert control of a
short time frames we can't exert control
over long time frames and an infinite
mindset is the total opposite infinite
mindset sees surprises as an exciting
thing and sees opportunity in
uncertainty and where is the finite
mindset one of the reasons they fear
newness and uncertainty is because the
finite mindset think of it like a
baseball game or a combat where they
practice and practice and practice and
rehearse and rehearse and rehearse or it
could be the same thing for a play right
they rehearse and rehearse and rehearse
so that there are no surprises and they
talk about muscle memory yeah you just
rely on your muscle memory there's no
thinking they all say that there's no
thinking right the infinite mindset the
thinking begins at the moment of
surprise the infinite mindset the
creativity begins at the moment that we
don't know what we're doing and that is
embraced as a magical moment rather than
fear that's right
in the uncertainty and the surprise
that's happening all around us is I'm
very careful not to use the term
opportunity because the opportunity we
have right now came at the expense
of lives came at the expense of a
tremendous amount of lives and horror
and suffering like this is like
centuries of suffering but what's unique
now is that there is this moment of well
can we fast forward some of the
infrastructure all systems that can be
adjusted removing police officers from
schools pulling down Confederate statues
renaming elementary schools or major
highways and now this isn't like a new
idea that surfaced a month ago I signed
a petition about pulling down and
Confederate monument like 25 years ago
right there been people on the front
lines of this and people on the front
lines of police reform for many many
generations and there's still all the
many organizations are still trying to
figure out the right thing to do there's
an opportunity for us to reconsider
systems instantly and there's an
opportunity for us to get highly
creative but we are at the precipice of
tremendous creativity where I cannot
wait and like I could jump up and scream
I'm so excited to see what comes out of
this it is time to throw down on the
conversations that we have been having
for centuries and start really thinking
about the creative solutions and be
raising her hand and willing to do it
six weeks ago nobody was willing to put
the term white and supremacy in their
mouths and suddenly say wait a second
how am i white supremacists how is my
boardroom how's my PNL sheet and now my
family members who voted for Trump
called me and they're like yo can we
talk about this reparations thing and
I'm like did you just say reparations
like we have a moment to leap and it
requires all of us to sit in the I don't
notice and sit in the constant front row
and paying attention so much is going to
have to evolve right now and we all have
to be very willing to sit in the I know
what I can do on myself I'm not sure
what that's gonna look like in my
relationship with my uncle Bob at
Thanksgiving I don't know what that's
gonna look like in a presidential I
don't know what that's gonna look like
from a societal perspective I'm very
curious to see how that's gonna change
my power and my freedom to move and go
chase my dreams but we all have to sit
in this like sacred gray of I know I
want to do better and I don't know yet
how to do
yeah this idea of leaning into your
relationships with vulnerability people
are always like okay so how do we have
our conversation with Uncle Bob who at
the Thanksgiving Day table might see
something misogynistic like all right
well y'all it's not just one time at a
Thanksgiving table it's you know decades
of comments said no one's ever caught
but oftentimes what I say to people as
they're both catching themselves calling
themselves in and calling other people
in is to lead with that vulnerability
and what I do is I'll call that person
up and be like hey I have a question for
you I'm struggling with something you
said and I'm trying to figure it out do
you have thoughts so this idea of
calling somebody in and saying I'm
really wrestling with something you said
you have thoughts about why I love this
idea of calling someone in it versus
calling someone out we have to stop this
because whenever we're calling out it's
about us performing for ourselves it's
about us reminding ourselves that we are
smart enough and therefore we are worthy
enough for our own love and it's binary
- I am writing you know it's totally
binary I'm right you're wrong this goes
back to the what we were talking about a
moment ago about admitting that we don't
know and that to your point and I saw
those same thing and there are people
who only know about policing from the
outside who were telling the police
here's what you have to do to fix it now
no one can debate that some of those
things are good but the question is is
can they actually work can they reform
police forces a thing that I love about
what is happening right now it's a
tension that has been released you know
nature abhors a vacuum nature abhors
imbalance and we see this in financial
markets when it becomes too imbalanced
there is a correction we actually call
it a correction where gross imbalance is
rebalanced and sometimes it causes pain
and huge financial loss because it's a
stock market crash but it's a balancing
of imbalance and that's what's happening
now this is a correction we were in a
period of massive massive imbalance and
inequality and inequality yep and
there's only so much tension a system
can take because nature abhors imbalance
and to the point where it just snaps and
nobody knows exactly the time or the
place it's gonna snap but if you leave
imbalance for too long it's gonna snap
and by the way this is the same between
two
people that's right when there's a
tension at some point somebody slams
their fist on the table and say why
won't you just listen to me or why do
you keep - it happens at some point
somebody snaps and that's what we're
watching we're watching a massive
correction so here's my hypothesis and I
would actually change the language a
little bit
I don't think nature allows things that
are inauthentic to thrive think about
all of the relationships you've been in
unless it's an authentic love it's not
gonna work yeah of course that is the
truth with a love relationship that is
the truth with a business if it's not
moral it's not gonna work it's the same
thing with a constitution nature does
not let lack of authenticity survive
because the species can't make it it
will extinguish itself it's like the
frogs in the rain forest they stop
reproducing when there's not enough
puddles to hang out in I don't think
you're going to see the population boom
of the next generation that we might
have previously very literally because
of climate change if you look at a
constitution that we all revere that has
exactly zero pronouns referencing her
and she it's not gonna survive the thing
that I think people forget about a
nation-state is that it's a culture and
cultures change with politics and
technology and time
I mean culture adapts and to invoke dr.
Carr's again he said I don't like belief
and of course I was like well I built a
career on the importance of belief and
so of course my first question from is
well what's your definition of belief
and I love it he said belief is we're
thinking stops belief is where you're
thinking stops and I believe in this and
beyond that it cannot be and I said well
if you don't like belief then what do
you embrace and he says I embrace
culture but culture is malleable and
that doesn't mean you abandon the values
and that doesn't mean you abandon
foundations but it does mean that you
can change it to keep it more relevant
and let it grow and survive and survive
and America now is still
America from 1776 or 17:81 everyone to
talk about the Constitution it's still
the same nation America is still the
same nation but of course we have to
adapt and we have to change which is why
the Constitution is interpreted because
it has to be interpreted through a
modern lens which I think our founding
fathers intended and a nation-state is
not a thing that you put in formaldehyde
and you preserve it in its original form
for a thousand years well you do leave
if that allows you to keep your power
FairPoint and then let's also talk about
what freedom actually means because
going back to the language in the
Constitution it has only ever referenced
white Christian men and who still are at
the top of the org chart be it in
political office in boardrooms on air it
is white Christian men the Constitution
is working and if I leave your audience
with no other ideas other then sit in
the grace of the grey hold the sacred
and we can deal with two contradicting
ads at the same time what is the sacred
end the sacred end is the truth and the
knowing that both things that can
contradict each other can exist at the
same time this idea that I want to be a
good mom but I also snap if I have to
ask my kids to brush their teeth after
four times this idea that I want to be
well intended but I might also cause
harm the idea that oh my gosh I am now
realizing I've been driving by that
Confederate statue for many many decades
and I never realized what it represented
this idea that you can be a white person
that has given up all of your resource
and just because of your race and the
way that it has been constructed with
and without language in this country you
can still cause harm it's part of the
grey it's part of this idea that like
you have to hold the sacred and you can
have loving parents that you trust so
much but not want to talk to them about
sex so the sacred end is the acceptance
that paradox or opposing points of view
or thoughts can exist simultaneously and
that's okay and we don't have to
sometimes choose right right so this
idea that like parents have to check
every single box or that partners have
to check every single box our friends
have to check
every single box my mom gave herself the
permission as a mom she said you know
Jenna I knew I could only raise you 57%
of the way I had to let the world do the
rest it's the same thing here right like
the roles that we play my favorite
sacred end and I talked about the
paradox of being human and I now know
what this is is it's a sacred end the
paradox of being human is every single
moment of every single day we are both
individuals and members of groups yeah
everyday families churches schools
communities whatever it is and we're
individuals in every single day we're
confronted with sometimes small
sometimes big decisions do i prioritize
myself at the expense of the group or do
i prioritize the group at the expense of
myself and there's an entire school of
thought that says you always put
yourself first because i'm until you're
taken care of you can't take care of the
group and there's another entire school
of thought that says no no you have to
take care of the group first because you
don't take care of the group there'll be
no one there to take care of you and
you're both right you're both wrong it's
a paradox yes and I would say though to
the ladder that every religion every
poet every philosopher and Simon's last
book whenever that is in 40 years from
now is going to say the latter not the
former if you're asking me now what that
balance is and by the way this is the
same reason that I disagree with
Maslow's hierarchy of needs which is too
often invoked right the mistake that
masses love me he put the the primary
that the number one thing that we all
need is food and shelter and then number
three was community and relationships
third rung up but I've never heard of
anyone committing suicide because they
were hungry they committed suicide
because they were lonely that's right
and the mistake that Maslov made is that
he only thought of us as individuals and
if you only think of as individuals he's
right food and shelter absolutely come
first but if you think of us as members
of community he's completely wrong so
he's only half right and so if you're
asking me you know if I were to produce
a new hire give needs where I put social
deep meaningful relationships and a
sense of belonging community first now
how do those two pyramids coexist I'm
not satisfied to say that one is right
and one is wrong it is not binary it is
gray it is uncomfortable however I do
believe because there's no such thing as
equal because sometimes you make
decisions where one thing has to be
sacrifice that there has to be bias and
that bias has to tilt towards community
because when push comes to shove as
social animals as human beings we are
recognized and want to be remembered for
the contribution we had in the lives of
others that's right
no one wants on their tombstone what
they did for themselves we want on our
tombstones what we did for others we
talked about legacy legacy is a
contribution to others and so we all
inherently have a sense that there is a
bias towards community towards somehow
sacrificing our individual interests for
the good of others even if it's our
children that there's a passing on and
so I think we inherently know it
practicing it is an entirely different
story or practicing in a country that's
prioritized by neri we talk about bias a
country that has over emphasized rugged
individualism that's right square
footage likes cars which is all about me
and all the bonuses and our companies
are given to you and your performance
even though none of us did well by
ourselves that's right it took our
bosses it took our colleagues that took
our friends it took support it took
sometimes our families it took a village
to help us be successful so that we
could hit our numbers to get our bonus
at the end of the year and yet we're
celebrated as you're wonderful look how
good you are
that's right would you please tell us
the things you want everybody to
remember to learn ok we're in really
hard times were in miraculous times
stick with it stay in the front seat
raise your hand don't beat yourself up
question yourself harder live in the
grey hold the secret and I'll see you on
the other side here's what I've learned
from talking to you
the thing that I'm taking away from this
is I love this idea of figuring out the
questions to ask and being comfortable
not knowing the answer and not even
knowing how to find the answer and that
the only way to find answers to
extremely difficult questions is to tell
others what our questions are tell
others that we don't know the answers to
our own questions and tell others that
we need help to find those answers and
that's called the journey that is what
it means to be human that's what it
means to build great companies what it
means to build great organ
what it means to build great nations and
our leaders are to model behavior
because the rest of us will follow our
leaders that's what we do we model the
behavior of our leaders American men
stopped wearing hats because John F
Kennedy was elected and he didn't wear a
hat and that's it we just stop wearing
hats we follow our leaders it's not
political and until our leaders get
really good at saying here are the
questions I don't know the answer and I
need help to find that answer mm-hmm
then the rest of us will get better at
it and anyone can be that leader it does
not require the people in positions of
authority to do that it requires any of
us to do that amongst our friends and we
will lead our friends to do the same
because if we are comfortable ourselves
to express that level of uncertainty and
vulnerability our friends will follow
yeah and and it's a real it's a real
gift that you'd be giving to yourself
into other people to role model that I
don't notice it invites other people to
also not know the I don't notice that's
what this is about this is about the I
don't known as and that the I don't
notice the gray is good if I can be
binary about the gray yeah
the gray is good way to wrap it up sigh
all right you're wonderful thank you so
much for this I hope you enjoyed this
bit of optimism if you'd like more
please subscribe wherever you like to
listen to podcasts I hope you'll join me
next time until then take care of
yourself and take care of each other
[Music]
you